But simply to experience it, and from
there you take, so here, here there
's nothing Martial, there's nothing, we do
n't call that a catastrophe, it's
that we understand that what's going to happen
there also has repercussions here, but if
you don't feel it, ultimately you
won't be able to build it in, and there,
either I push there but ultimately
look, nothing happens
there, or I push, all of this is there, in that
case we immediately have our weaknesses,
or
else, and
there, and this kind of little exercise, and here
I insist, this is an exercise that can
highlight some of our weaknesses,
for example, do I go down to
try to go up, do I go up
here to try to project him, do
I only work catastrophe by catastrophe,
so put
3, and there you must have an impact
not only on him, but there,
nothing happened on him, but there, nothing
happened
simultaneously, and what is this, this is
the 10th
blow, the 10th kouidjo, what is  I
do this when I throw him
backward and I have his
neck, his wrist, the 10th strike. That's the only one where I
'll use both ends
of my
JO simultaneously. The
10th strike,
though, I'll be at the top and bottom, I
'll have contact here and contact
at the bottom. It's the only one where both
ends of the JO will be used
simultaneously.
Okay, so we'll come back to that in a moment.
So, get into position in a
completely artificial way, but
the point of this exercise is to manage
to have an effect here and here
simultaneously. Okay, please.